welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
complete series recap of Barry meet
Barry Berkman who's currently working as
a Hitman in Cleveland but today his
manager Fuchs has something exciting for
him a job in Sunny Los Angeles working
in the big leagues with the Chechen mob
Barry's contact here is NoHo Hank a
hilarious character who's way too nice
and friendly to be a gangster so it's a
standard hit to take out the guy the
boss's wife was sleeping with Barry
follows him to a common site in Los
Angeles but something Barry's never seen
before an amateur acting class his Mark
Ryan Madison recruits Barry to be his
scene partner and now that Barry's been
on stage oh he's caught the acting bug
Barry makes friends with the whole
acting class especially Sally Reed who
he's instantly spent with the instructor
is legendary washed up actor Gene
Cousino who breaks the bad news to Barry
kid you're just not good but Barry who
was on the verge of an existential
crisis anyway doesn't want to kill
people anymore so he launches into the
true story of how when he got out of the
Marines the only thing he knew how to do
was kill and so his family friend Monroe
Fuchs recruited him to be a Hitman Mr
Cousino assumes this was his audition
monologue he's like actually kid that
was pretty good you're in it's a very
Tales view cause I'm done being a hit
man I'm gonna be an actor now but fuse
can't have this Barry is making him good
money and of course he points out Barry
doesn't do the hit the chechens will
kill him so Barry goes to kill Ryan but
the chechens already did it Barry was
taking too long they got worried decided
to take them both out so Barry goes
Terminator mode and takes out this whole
car the chechins of course retaliate but
in that car was their best hit man now
he's dead they need Barry skills Barry's
like hey I don't do that anymore I'm an
actor now but I'll do one last hit for
you guys we'll call it even it should be
a nice easy hit against their rival gang
the bolivians but to NoHo Hank mailed a
bullet to Bolivia and he wants Barry to
wait so they'll get it at the same time
it'll be dramatic so in the meantime
Barry gets to focus on acting class
where Mr Cousino becomes a mentor to him
and he and Sally strike up a
relationship but detective Janice Moss
is investigating Ryan's death and NoHo
Hank left his webcam in the car so
they've got a picture of Barry luckily
it's pretty blurry she interviews the
acting class but Barry's got an alibi he
and Fuchs have a good system but Gene
Cousino is instantly smitten with her
and despite her skepticism he's a
romantic guy they hit it off so Barry
completes his one last hit but Fuchs
wants to keep making money with the
chechins and volunteers buried to take
out the whole Bolivian Stash House Now
Barry's met up with a friend from the
Marines who lives in La Chris and Chris
introduces him to some other Marines
including Taylor the crazy hot dad who
instantly realizes Barry's real job and
is like yo I want in Barry does need
help taking out the stash house but
Taylor literally Leroy Jenkins right in
there takes him all out himself Barry's
hope is to pass Taylor onto fuse so he
can stop killing and focus on acting so
Barry's actual final hits will be the
Bolivian leader crystal ball now come to
town but Taylor shows up with the whole
car full of Marines including Chris who
never saw combat and Taylor throws out
Barry's plan decides to go with his own
plan bum rush right at him which you
know does not go well Taylor and the
other guy are killed but Barry and Chris
get away and Chris is freaking out we
gotta go to the cops Barry's like hey
man you gotta just chill but Chris makes
it clear he'll never be able to keep
this secret and it's an awful tense
moment as Barry and Chris now realize
Barry's gonna have to kill him and so
Barry kills his friend Chris oh that's
rough meanwhile Barry's been having
trouble acting he's really not good Mr
cousino's advice was to use his real
life experience is to access these
emotions and tonight after killing Chris
he's swarming with emotions just in time
to bring real deep sadness to his one
big line oh man Barry just acted his
great delivery set Sally up to give a
knockout performance and the agent in
the audience loved it wants to sign her
which is a breakthrough for her trying
to be an actress in La is a very hard
but now Barry finally has it out with
Fuchs I am done with killing starting
now but crystal ball is still alive and
turns out super nice guy
but to kill him unfortunately it's War
it was really Fuchs who instigated this
the chechins are going to kill him and
Barry but NoHo Hank gives Barry the
heads up so Barry takes out the whole
Chechen garage he hates Fuchs now but
still had to save him he drives him to
the airport I never want to see you
again I'm done with this life starting
now NoHo Hank now finds himself the
leader of the Chechen mob and makes
peace with crystal ball they joined
forces to be a nice friendly gang
together and the cops investigating
through a series of coincidences blame
everything on Taylor and Ryan Madison so
a short time later berries live in the
dream dating Sally acting's going great
on a weekend getaway at Mr cousino's
cabin but at dinner Mr Cousino mentions
Barry's audition monologue about the
Marine turned Hitman this prompts Janice
to take another look at that photo and
now that she knows him yeah it's
definitely Barry Barry tries to talk to
her look I was mixed up with some bad
stuff but that's not my life anymore we
can just ignore this but she's a good
cop Barry I can't let that happen and so
once again Barry has to kill her and
he's like okay no more killing starting
now so in Barry season two Mr Cousino is
devastated by Janice's death and wants
to shut down acting class but Barry
can't have that acting class is the best
thing in his life so he proposes they
work out their feelings on stage he
tells a story from back in the Marines
the first person he ever killed which
the whole class assumes was traumatic
but was actually a really happy moment
for him Mr Cousino loves this new idea
so the class works on a Showcase of all
their most dramatic memories most of
which are more funny than tragic and
NoHo Hank is living his dream the
bolivians and chechnyans make a great
team up and he and Cristobal are hitting
it off but when crystal ball wants to
bring in the Burmese led by Esther this
ruins NoHo Hank's Vibe so Hank pays a
visit to his old friend Barry who owes
him one and forces him to do this one
last job but when it comes to it Barry
can't pull the trigger so he makes a
deal to instead train the chechins to be
an army so in the meantime Barry works
on a scene and tries to figure out how
to tell a war story that won't
traumatize the whole class in private he
tells Mr Cousino about the time he saved
his friend Albert's life but that story
ends with him going into Terminator mode
and killing an obviously innocent person
Mr Cousino understands tells Barry it's
okay but yeah you absolutely shouldn't
tell that story instead he is very
focused on Sally's scene about your
abusive ex-boyfriend which is awkward
when he shows up in person he's acting
all nice at first but it becomes clear
he's still a terrible person just trying
to convince her not to do the scene and
Barry was gonna kill this guy but the
timing doesn't work out and so acting
out the scene Barry once again Taps into
his awful memories and actually does an
incredible powerful performance Sally's
first draft was the empowering story of
the night she finally told him off and
left him but she soon has to admit to
herself that's not how it happened she
forgave him so she and Barry do the true
version which is so much more
heartbreaking but incredibly powerful
Sally's agent came to this rehearsal and
was like whoa that was really good and
though Sally's career has been better
than ever she's still being wasted on
Tiny background roles but now they land
her a leading role in a show about abuse
unfortunately it's awful drivel and she
has to turn it down very meanwhile
waiting in the lobby to give her a ride
the agent's like hey man you're pretty
tall I've got an audition for you for a
lead role in a feature film he's like
wow this acting thing's easy now Barry
has successfully trained the chechins
and they've come to love and respect him
NoHo Hank says goodbye gives Barry the
pin the debt is paid but back in
Cleveland Fuchs has continued doing hits
with someone less professional and is
instantly arrested and his DNA matches
the mystery tooth they found in the
Chechen garage so this guy puts it all
together so a few swims back to LA to
wear a wire against Barry but luckily
Barry doesn't want to talk to him later
though Barry's happy to see him because
he's the only one he can talk to about
his real life stuff at least you have a
complicated love-hate relationship but
in the end Barry does mention he killed
Janice and so now Barry's caught but
this detective doesn't arrest Barry he
blackmails him into killing the guy his
wife left him for turns out though this
guy's a Taekwondo champion and it turns
into a full episode long crazy fight
scene they end up at a store where he
kills this detective and then is shot so
Barry walks out of there real casually
after this week's tries to get Barry
back in business but Barry tells him off
again I have a new Mentor now Mr Cousino
so if he exposes his private
investigator Kenneth Goulet goes to
threaten Mr Cousino soberry blows his
big audition and walks out of there
which ironically makes him like him even
more Fuchs LED Cousino to Janice's car
and is going to frame him for her murder
Barry gets there just in time to think
quick and drop the Chechen pin in the
trunk the debt is paid oh yeah this was
the chechens and naturally Tonight is
their big performance but Sally's been
having second thoughts about doing such
a personal thing in front of so many
people so she goes back to the original
version where she tells him off which is
not true but hugely popular and
tonight's the night that NoHo Hank is
going to lead his new Army against the
Burmese unfortunately they're caught and
and things look Bleak Blackberry trained
these guys real well and they get out of
it it's about to be an all-out gang war
but Fuchs is still trying to get in with
this crew manage just a broker a piece
with himself at the center but when
Barry learns that Fuchs is there he goes
into murder mode shoots everyone in the
building trying to get the Fuchs which
horribly includes all these Chechen kids
he just trained that look up to him it's
only after futes gets away that Barry
realizes what he's just done and has a
bit of a mental break and Barry doesn't
know the worst thing Fuchs did because
he did tell kusuno it was Barry who
killed Janus so in Barry season 3
Sally's career is taking off she's the
lead and writer of a show Joplin about
her hometown and abusive relationships
Barry is a supportive boyfriend but he's
a walking shell right now in the midst
of a psychotic break it gets worse when
Mr Cousino finally confronts Barry he's
got him at gunpoint gonna force him to
turn himself in unfortunately his gun
falls apart so now it's Barry who has
him at gunpoint but Barry really doesn't
want to kill his mentor Mr Cousino and
so he comes up with a brilliant idea if
he can land in Mr Cousino an acting job
that'll make up for killing his
girlfriend he asks Sally to get Mr kuzno
a job on her show unfortunately that's
not how it works and Barry flips out
goes absolutely crazy starts yelling at
her which is super awkward in front of
her co-workers on a show about abusive
relationships so instead Barry goes to
the casting director he knows who has
infinite roles for a tall brooding white
guys but she's got nothing from Mr
Cousino he burned all his bridges in the
industry but had his audition Barry
makes an impassion case that Mr Cousino
deserves another chance and so they give
him a little roll and so Barry got him a
small part like Hey we're even now but
Mr Cousino breaks character to punch
Barry in the face until him off which
ironically was perfect for the scene
they want to bring him back in a
recurring role and so from a combination
of fear for his family and not wanting
to upset his new better life he decides
to let Perry go Sally's career is
fantastic too the critics love her new
show but when a co-worker points out
what Barry did was not okay Sally
finally realizes that and breaks up with
him so Joplin's released on the front
page but it's almost immediately
replaced turns out the algorithm doesn't
like it so they're not gonna promote it
Barry was just moving out so he's there
to comfort Sally he's like hey I could
break into that producer's house and you
know take pictures of her sleeping to
freak around and stuff but that's not
the comfort Sally was looking for she's
like no no we're still breaking up so
Barry goes for relationship advice from
NoHo Hank who is happily dating crystal
ball it's a little awkward that Barry
went crazy and murdered all of their
friends but you know bygones be bygones
now the cops investigated the monastery
shooting but NoHo Hank spun a great tale
for him blamed it all on the mystery man
Fuchs whose real identity is the
legendary Chechen assassin The Raven and
they've got him tucked away in chechnya
as a future scapegoat just in case so
Hank and crystal ball are free to live a
happy life together until Crystal Ball's
boss comes to town to get Vengeance on
the chechens and so Hank recruits Barry
to take these new bolivians out with a
sketchy bomb he bought on eBay and the
app doesn't work so Barry's Gotta Wait
on customer service still finally boom
but now the boss's daughter comes to
town to take Vengeance for her father
and they instantly raid the Chechen
operation but now the cops rate the
chechins at the same time so it turns
into an epic mess but the bolivians also
come to NoHo Hank's house and kidnap
crystal ball turns out the boss's
daughter is his wife meanwhile Fuchs is
living the dream in chechnya thanks in
part to his hot Chechen Handler she
tells him the folk tale of the Thousand
ghost Panthers and how you gotta let go
of Vengeance but he takes the opposite
lesson from it comes back to the States
as Kenneth Goulet goes to all the people
that Barry's killed over the years tells
them Barry did it hoping one of them
might take Vengeance his best bet is the
Marine Taylor's sister but she's in a
real hardcore Motocross gang who
instantly shoots him but he survives and
is Nurse to health once again by a
beautiful young woman so when Barry gets
a call from Chris's wife inviting him to
dinner bury his head Nova there only to
find himself randomly ambushed by a
Motocross gang it's another crazy
extended action sequence where things
get way out of hand but Barry makes it
to dinner but Kenneth Goulet was here
yeah told her Barry killed Chris and she
poisoned him so Barry is dying and has a
vision in the afterlife where he's
reunited with all the people he's killed
who are not happy to see him but in the
end he's found by Ryan Madison's father
who instead drives Barry to the hospital
and kills himself so Barry survives and
he comes home to find Sally waiting for
him Sally took a job as a writer on a
bad show but the show next door's new
showrunner is Natalie their friend from
the acting class who Sally brought along
as her assistant and seeing her success
after Sally's own failure she snaps and
yells at her with an unhinged rant which
unfortunately she she recorded and now
Sally's career is all the way done so
now Sally is ready for Revenge Hey Barry
you want to break into your house and
stuff just as Barry's trying to talk her
out of it the last Motocross guy comes
and starts a fight he's gonna kill Sally
but she gets the upper hand and oh she
kills this guy Sally is horribly in
shock but he's like it's gonna be okay
but Sally decides it's time to leave
down for a bit meanwhile NoHo Hank has
gone down to Bolivia to rescue crystal
ball where he's instantly captured and
it's a crazy scene as he's listening to
the chechins on the other side of the
wall being eaten by a tiger but he does
manage to escape and save his man
crystal ball meanwhile Fuchs is still
recruiting his Panther Vengeance Army
and this one is detective Janice Moss's
father but Fuchs is trying to manipulate
the wrong guy here he was an
interrogator back in nam instantly just
drives Fuchs to the police station now
the FBI has just sent an agent to deal
with this Raven and turns out it is
Barry's friend Albert from the Marines
whose life he saved when he hears about
Barry's potential involvement he talks
to Fuchs one-on-one and Fuchs basically
tells him the truth but turns him into a
Vengeance Panther 2 by telling him about
Barry killing their mutual friend Chris
in the meantime though Fuchs is going to
jail and when he learns they think he's
this legendary Chechen assassin he goes
with it yeah call me the Raven so as
Barry's bearing Motocross guy his friend
Albert tracks him down and Barry's
having a full breakdown Albert's like
look man you saved my life I'm not going
to turn you in but the killing has to
stop right now meanwhile Mr cousino's
career is having a Resurgence but now
Genesis father pays him a visit to get
to the bottom of this Berry business
it's an intense interrogation scene
where long story short he breaks him
completely zacusuno calls Barry hey he
knows everything so Barry's got to go in
there and kill one last time but it was
one time too many because it was a setup
oh the cops are all here Janice's father
getting revenge for his daughter kusuno
turning in Barry so in season four
Barry's in prison and also here is his
old Mentor Fuchs Fuchs thinks Barry
wants to kill him again so he makes a
deal for protection to wear a wire
against Barry again but Barry's in a bad
place right now in the middle of a full
mental breakdown and in his own way
Fuchs really does love Barry so the
deal's off he's here to help him Sally
Reed flew home after her near-death
experience so she missed the the bigger
news that Barry's arrested for murdering
Janice back in L.A Sally finds her
acting career is doubly over now for her
breakdown video and dating a killer she
gets advice from Gene Cousino when your
own career is over it's time to teach
Sally briefly takes over the acting
class where she meets a model who's
landed a big part and could have a new
career as her acting coach but
eventually she has to face Barry who
tries to explain I'm not a bad person
and Sally admits to herself that she
feels safe with him so Barry has a new
plan he's willing to testify against
NoHo Hank in the organized crime he's
worked for in exchange for witness
protection so he and Sally can live
happily ever after now no ho Hank is
happily retired with his partner Crystal
Ball but soon they have a new idea to
unite rival gangs at Dave and Buster's
for a happy friendly crime Utopia
they're gonna make money not importing
drugs but importing construction sand
which is apparently even more valuable
and so once again they're living the
dream Hanks like Cristobal come on out
of there because wait what's this the
sand funnels sucks them all down it was
real close but crystal ball survives
he's like oh I'm so sorry you weren't
supposed to be in there see Hank was
approached by his old employers the
Chechen mob who are like you absolutely
can't run your own friendly game without
us you have to take them out and bring
us in so Hank did it for his and
Cristobal safety but now Crystal Ball's
like dude you murdered all our new
friends like I do even are you it's a
tear-jerking scene as Crystal Ball's
leaving him and Hank's like no please
you can't go because he knows too much
if he's not with Hank Hank has to kill
him no oh Hank you are the comic relief
character why are you making me feel
feelings meanwhile Hank hears that
Barry's working with the feds so of
course he has to have him killed but he
picks an assassin from a gadget podcast
where the gadgets always backfire so it
doesn't go well and Barry escapes Barry
goes to see Sally like hey run away with
me and she's like yeah you know I'm in
we immediately cut to the middle of
nowhere which has previously been the
setting for Barry's dream sequences but
this isn't a Dream It's really happening
we got a 10-year time Jump Barry and
Sally are living the quiet life in the
middle of nowhere with her new son John
Barry's in full dad mode trying to be a
good father to make up for his
questionable past meanwhile Sally is
working at a diner and spends her time
off binge drinking and hate watching her
former assistant's successful new show
but there's news back from Hollywood
they're making a movie about Barry story
and Gene cousino's consult thing so
Barry's got to go kill him when he heard
Barry escape to prison Cousino went to
hide out when he saw the shadow at the
door he shot but it was just his son
bringing him some dinner he survived he
fled the country and found in her peace
and he's not here to make the movie he
wants to shut it down to honor Janice's
memory but Barry doesn't know that he's
here to kill him and as he's sneaking in
oh someone grabs him yeah Janice Moss's
father's been hunting him all this time
he works his interrogation Magic on
Barry and finds out about the big bag of
cash he gave to Cousino that Cousino
never mentioned so in a fake meeting
with Daniel Day-Lewis they lure Cousino
into an ambush because with the info
they have looking at it from the wrong
angle it looks like Barry was working
for Cousino the whole time and killed
Janice moss on his orders they don't
know about Barry's real boss Fuchs who
was beaten real bad after Barry's Escape
but he never talked and gave Barry up
because he didn't actually know anything
but the other prisoners don't know that
so it earns Fuchs a ton of street cred
and now that Fuchs is released from
prison he's undergone an epic
transformation he's fully become his
fake Alter Ego The Raven he goes to work
for no ho Hank who's transitioned into a
wildly successful legitimate business
but of course there's still the criminal
underbelly so he sets Fuchs in his gang
up in a nice new house but at dinner
when Fuchs congratulates him for being
bloodthirsty and killing crystal ball
Hank freaks out it seems like he's fully
repressed that and he's like oh Fuchs
This Means War it's classic gang war
Shenanigans where Hank's plans don't
work out well Hank's gonna make peace by
giving him Barry who fukes blames for
betraying him back in prison when Barry
didn't come home Sally and John came out
to LA and Hank's guys grab him Barry
escaped from Mr Moss's garage so now
Hank calls him I've got your wife and
kid here then he calls Fuchs hey Barry's
on the way come on over and you know you
can kill him so Barry's ready to go into
Terminator mode for an epic final action
shootout that takes office but before
Barry arrives Phoenix and Hank have a
talk and it goes bad both gangs end up
shooting each other so by the time Barry
gets there the action's all over Fuchs
ended up saving Barry's son and they
have a final nod of respect and uh he
runs off but NoHo Hank does not escape
this is where he dies meanwhile Mr
Cousino is gonna go to jail for Barry's
crimes and Barry finally comes to the
realization I should confess to clear
his name but Mr Cousino still has that
gun and when he sees Barry in his house
he shoots him Barry looks up and says oh
wow then miss shoots him in the head a
few years later Sally Reed has become a
High School Drama teacher and is living
a reasonably normal life but tonight's
her son John goes over to a friend's
house to watch the movie they made about
his dad Barry it is a hilarious
dramatization that gets everything
totally wrong it paints Barry as the
noble hero and Mr Cousino as a
manipulator that was working with the
Chechen mob and so Barry kind of wins as
his son gets to think of him as a good
guy and that's where Barry comes to an
end if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]